- Okay, I'll take this one.
Honestly, I'm not a big
fan of Hagrid, so...
- What? What?
(upbeat electronic music)
- Hello, Internet. My name's Sara,
and welcome to Fan or Failure,
the show where pop culture fans
fight to prove their devotion.
- I am a huge Harry Potter fan.
It's the book that got me into books.
- I listen to the audiobooks once a year,
I used to write fanfiction.
I'm also worried that my friends
and family care about this a lot,
and they might disown me if I don't win.
- If you get a question
right, you get a point.
If you get it wrong,
you have to read an incredibly
disparaging sentence
about Harry Potter.
- No.
- Let's get started.
- What is the name of the company
where Vernon Dursley works?
Is it Bloomturns, Tunnings,
Furrutons, or Grunnings?
- Oh no.
(Kendall laughs)
(tense music)
- Oh, my handwriting's quite nice today.
- All right. Let's see your answers.
Those are both correct.
You've avoided humiliation
for the first question.
How much money do you need
to include a hot chocolate
with your Knight Bus ticket?
Is it...
13 Sickles, 29 Knuts,
four Sickles, or six Galleons?
- I have no idea.
- For hot chocolate?
- [Sara] For hot chocolate
on the Knight Bus.
- I don't know how to spell Knuts.
- Oh shit.
(laughs)
- One, two, three.
Unfortunately, unfortunately,
you're both wrong.
(laughter)
- What?
- You're both wrong. It was 13 Sickles.
- No.
- That's some expensive hot chocolate.
- That's super expensive.
- Oh you're selecting one for me.
(light xylophone music)
(sighs)
- Donald Trump reminds me of Dumbledore.
- Twilight is a better
story than Harry Potter.
- Weird you would say that.
Here's your next question folks.
Wolfsbane and Monkshood are
technically the same plant.
What is that plant called?
Is it called Aconite, Tanzanite,
Melanite, or Baphonite?
- Hm.
- Can I tell you what it does instead?
I can tell you that.
- No, you must choose a name.
There's no option E.
- All right. I think...
- One, two, three, let's see those boards.
- It looks like Robin is correct.
- [Kendall] Dammit!
- It is aconite.
- No.
- Kendall, unfortunately
that does me you have to
read a horrible sentence
about the thing you love.
- If the Sorting Hat were real,
it would sort these books into
the trash where they belong.
- This next game is called...
Whose eyes are these?
I'll show you three pictures,
of eyes that I have drawn,
because I couldn't get the
rights to use the actual photos,
and you guys will tell
me whose eyes are these?
And unfortunately, the punishment for this
is not saying disparaging
sentences about Harry Potter.
It is, however, ripping
pages from the book.
- No way.
- No. No.
- So, pray that you do
not get these wrong.
- No.
- Whose eyes are these?
Whose eyes are these?
- Are those eyebrows, or is that--
- These are eyebrows, come on.
You can't tell? I'm offended.
(laughs)
- It's from the movie?
- The books are words.
There's no pictures.
- You're a pretty good artist.
- Thank you.
Whose eyes are these?
No. These are the eyes of Luna Lovegood.
- No, they're not.
- They 100% are.
And now it is time for your punishment.
- Oh, god.
(inhales)
- Just rip out you thought maybe oh,
J.K. Rowling's editor should have told her
to shorten this chapter.
It's too long, goes on to long.
- All right.
Professor McGonagall's
getting mad at Harry
and Ron and Hermione.
- That happens like 20 times.
(ripping)
- That's so wrong.
- I know.
- Okay, I'll take this one.
Honestly, I'm not a big
fan of Hagrid, so...
- Whose eyes are these?
- Are their pupils meant to be off?
- Nope. I messed up.
(laughs)
- I've got nothing.
- Let's see em.
It's unfortunately neither of them.
- No.
- It was Remus Lupin's eyes.
- Dammit, that was my other one.
- That was going to be my second one, too.
(groans)
- Yeah, sometimes second
choice is the better choice.
- Oh, this is when Hagrid got
drunk and got a dragon egg.
- I'm gonna rip out child abuse pages,
from when he's living with the Dursleys.
- I love those bits.
(tearing)
- All right, this is the
last set of eyes I have here.
Whose eyes are these?
- And it's like a main character?
It's not like Madame Hooch or something?
(laughs)
- No, it's not an obscure strange person.
- I haven't got the faintest idea.
(sighs)
- Let's see those answers
on one, two, three.
- Unfortunately, those are both wrong.
- No.
- These were the eyes
of Neville Longbottom.
- No way.
- They were indeed his eyes.
He has eyebrows just like--
- Can we see? Can we see?
- Can you see it again?
- It is Neville Longbottom.
- Unfortunately, that
is the end of our game,
however it does mean
that Robin is the winner,
that he is the greatest
wizard in all the land.
And he wins the Golden Critch.
- It's a Snitch.
(singing)
- This is a lemon?
(upbeat electronic music)